نحن الان في منطقه المقابر المحيطه بميدان
مسجد السيده نفيسه هذه المنطقه كانت حديث
المصريين عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
بسبب قرارات ازاله والهدف هو انشاء محاور
مروريه جديده
تستمر عمليات الهدم والازاله للعديد من
المقابر في مناطق الامام الشافعي والسيده
عائشه والسيده نفيسه ما اثار لغطا دفعه
وزاره السياحه والاثار لاصدار بيان ينفي
ازاله اي مقابر اثريه ويصف الجدل الدائره
بالشائعات متخصصون وضحوا ان المقابر
المسجله كاثار لا يمكن هدمها او ازالتها
وفقا للقانون اتحدى ان واحد يثبت لي ان
هناك اثر ازيل
فيش ليه الدوله
لجات للاثار
ادونا مخطط الاثار اللي موجود عندكم طب ما
احنا على مدار التاريخ المصري
ازيلت جبانات لا حصر لها زي جبانه الرويعي
اللي اتعمل مكانها ميدان العتبه والمباني
اللي موجوده فيه والمسرح القومي والحاجات
دي كلها ولكن الانتقادات ركزت على ان
قرارات الازاله تشمل مقابر لعدد من
الشخصيات التاريخيه المصريه والعربيه
بالاضافه الى ان بعض المقابر تحمل طرازا
معماريا تاريخيا يعكس تراثا لتلك الحقب
منطقه ديت هي منطقه كان بدا فيها الدفن من
وقت دخول سيدنا عمرو بن العاص لما اخذ جبل
مقطم ودفن بعد كده يعني الموت حوله
وبالتالي المنطقه ديت لو احنا يعني بدانا
عملنا فيها فرقه سريع حاجه اسمها فرق
انقاذ حنقدر نطلع منها اثار لا حصر لها
بعض الورثه من اصحاب المقابر تقدموا بطعون
ضد قرارات الازاله الازمه وصلت الى
البرلمان مش عشان طريق ولا محور ولا ولا
كوبري جديد اهد او اعمل ازاله لكوبري او
لضريح يكون له طابع مميز جدا ومفترض ان
انا استغله
بصوره سياحيه جميله وحافظ عليه وبالعكس
اطوره واخليه فعلا يبقى متحف مفتوح سواء
للمصريين او للاجانب
ويستمروا الانقسام بين فريق يفضل استمرار
عمليات التوسعات المروريه للمدينه
المزدحمه وفريق اخر يطالب بالحفاظ على
ملامح مصر التاريخيه احمد عثمان العربيه
القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات